all right Billy what's up Billy uh
where's your girl where are you from
originally I'm from Riverside California
Riverside tell me about your family well
I've come from a long line of Outlaws
uh my dad was a
transcode wearing Cadillac Drive-In bull
horns on the front cowboy hat wild
Outlaw you mean uh x-con
he was in your life oh he was in my
library when he wasn't in prison
but uh he does he's died in July so I'm
sorry it's all right we all got to go
sometimes how would you describe your
childhood
uh I mean I was the oldest before I got
a brother
uh and two seasons or two twin sisters I
was the oldest so I was a man in the
house my dad was gone I uh
you know me took care of my family best
I could and I pretty much became the
Father Figure in my family
and then uh
I mean it was normal breeding for the
most part my mom had struggle with meth
addiction you know me and then that
eventually turned into whatever it is
chaotic house getting raided when we
were kids uh people all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] going on I mean yeah in and out of
prison here and there you finish High
School yep in prison oh I see GD but
regular school you went how far uh
regular school I was gonna drop down
like whatever freshman year went but I
went to all the schools being people
loved juvenile hall uh you know you got
any ganks yeah we know I didn't get into
games until I was like 18 though but
um when I went to prison I mean you guys
yeah I became a skinny right when I went
to prison and then uh
so in the gangs just so the audience
understands it's more racial oh yeah
yeah the blacks are there you know
whether you're a blood or a [ __ ] you end
up being all in the same yeah but down
here in Southern California like
everybody's like I'm like a white ghetto
kid really I mean I grew up in a
neighborhood like a body old part of my
neighborhood so I gotta listen to rap
music I do it I mean I'm all around
whatever I'm not some big big like
klansman or something you know I mean
mine's more like demographic like we all
know that if you're white boy like you
said you got Chris black you got Chris
Bloods they're gonna run up on you so
the white boy's gonna eventually you
know congregate with each other you know
just defend each other are you kind of
like peer pressured into being a white
you know I think you identify with it
more than anything I mean you identify
with what what you what you feel
comfortable with you mean and if
somebody's I mean you got people that
have to go outside of their identity to
become something else you know I mean
like so if you have a white crib they
always got to become black in some way
or if they if they're if they're white
Mexican they got to become full-on so
they know and it's like I never I could
lose my identity my dad would whip my
ass I mean so would you consider
yourself a racist
um
I'm more of a racist in the sense that I
believe that I mean we shouldn't be
missing and intermixing like uh sexually
I mean but I found a race like later on
in life I thought I was always this pure
Aryan Gene I used to study Eugenics and
all this stuff and all the white power
propaganda I was super into it and then
my son got taken I had a I had a son
when I was in when I was 16 and I was in
prison he got taken and I guess they hit
me with this federal law where the like
the Indian tribes if you have any kind
of relation to any kind of Indian tribe
and my grandpa was a Comanche Indian I
found that out later in life and that's
I was like what the you mean I can't I
love my grandpa you mean so identify
with what I am so I kind of dropped a
lot of that white power stuff now I mean
yeah how old are you uh 38 38. and what
are you doing for support yourself now
hustle hustling no I'm trying to I'm
trying to I got out of prison with
nothing you mean so like I've been
trying to struggle I got a business
degree when I was in prison I did a lot
a lot of stuff in there but I'm trying
to make make something to myself create
a business or some kind of
entrepreneurial [ __ ] you know like try
to figure something out looking back at
your life do you
do you have regrets of things you wish
you had done of course I mean I I would
say regressed I love who I am you know I
love who I love the people that are my
in my life I love
um the decisions I made I wouldn't trade
it in for the world in a sense but I
mean I've wasted a lot of time I know
that but in the same time like some of
the stuff out here that everybody can
put in puts in a higher pedestal than
what it really is because when you're in
prison you have all this time of
thinking and like adapt to your
surroundings but like get to know
yourself you know what I mean and I hear
people don't do that you don't have no
time to do that you mean so I don't
really regret going to prison I do
regret some of the pain I caused but
what do you make of the the new
generation of of males or or gangs that
are out here well I was I just recently
had another son with somebody and that's
what I'm what I'm really concerned of is
is the mark that we leave on this planet
is what is what a man is you know what I
mean like it doesn't like one of my
famous like you know Alexander the Great
right
yeah I read this poem recently that
talked about when he died
what he did was he told his generals
straight up I want you to bring me the
best Roman doctors right when I die I
want them to be the ones that carry my
casket I mean and he goes I want you to
line the streets with all the riches
that I've made all my wealth I mean in
general why would you do that he goes
I'm gonna leave an impact on this planet
I mean so that people understand what
this really is about and by being buried
by these doctors the doctors were taken
to where his grave was right and that
was telling him that no matter what
there's it's inevitable it's inevitable
that you're gonna have to face that end
you know so no matter what doctors are
here they're never gonna Escape that
okay and the riches that you make you
can't take it with you and that that was
pretty impactful for me I mean like
because it's true none of this [ __ ]
really matters it's the impact that you
leave on people that you that you're
here with the it's just the impact that
you leave you I mean the mark
oh what's your biggest fear now be fear
[Music]
going unnoticed not leaving that not
leaving nothing
not leaving that Mark you mean
other than that I don't fear nothing
what kind of stuff were you getting into
as a younger man
oh what kind of stuff like what got you
into prison oh I was a little while when
I was younger uh how many years have you
done 14 14. well yeah yeah 14 yeah
yeah I did 14 years
um before that I mean from 11 I got
busted my first time when I was 11 for
like some you know crazy whatever
whatever stuff I did I broke into
something or something but I went
juvenile hall when I was 11 from 11 to
18. I was uh
in and out juvenile hall probably on the
streets maybe like a year and a half and
then from there it was 14 years straight
bam I went in with four years for uh
carjacking
and uh shooting at somebody and then I
ended up catching two consecutive terms
inside for stabbing child molesters and
then
14 years later I was out
the life in prison is almost more
violent than on the streets oh yeah of
course yeah but it's different because
Society expects the people that get like
when it comes to child molesters like
well you would have thought we'd get an
Adam boy for that [ __ ] I mean but for
some reason the society don't really or
at least his correctional system he's
looking at more people staying in prison
so they don't care but like people on
the streets expect people that that hurt
their family members and she'd go in
there and get that retribution to me so
I always thought you just blast one
around there blast one around the yard
so I just do it right on the yard and
they're going to court I'm like what the
[ __ ] going on here it's money I mean
it's a justice system they don't give a
[ __ ] about that [ __ ] but yeah people
expect people to almost get slashed and
[ __ ] beat up and [ __ ] destroyed
that's what's supposed to happen to him
when you heard innocent people you're
gonna be you're gonna be victimized
that's what your karma is you know I
mean but I had to pay the price for that
too all right
what other kind of things were you doing
to survive
well yeah right here on the streets all
on the streets uh I like the tax people
I like tag people run a mug you mean uh
you do my my dominance I guess
I mean I like the life I mean but when
you get older I mean it comes with the
price too I've been shot I mean I just
got shot two years ago in the head 257.
shot me right here hit me in the frontal
lobe came back practicing my school
wrote it alongside my school came my
backside of my ear drop me in the neck
bullet still inside me went past my car
artery packed my lung my heart stopped
about and it's from my spine you got a
lot of interesting tattoos oh yeah it
was on the back of your head oh those
are my gang leaders
our Sage boots we're calling red boots
and then a lot of my sheets are like
like [ __ ] CDC type [ __ ] you know I mean
like this is a pig you know getting his
next uh stab with a screwdriver by
comrade
you got the captain getting his throat
slit
no remorse
I'm anti I'm anti-police but in the
sense I like I also have a view I have
like a slight review when it comes to
like Authority when it comes to that
[ __ ] like I I I don't like corruption in
cops or the fact that they get power
hungry and try to
um I don't know use that kind of [ __ ]
against people when it I think this
should be like a moral High Ground you
mean instead of just everything black
and white or whatever like if I was a
cop I'd probably be the most corrupt cop
that there was but I'd also be the most
[ __ ] righteous cop there is I mean
somehow I'd balance it out you know I
mean like I would be [ __ ] one you
gotta go they got to go the ones they
gotta say they got they they get a pass
you mean
that makes sense we're all still human
yeah we are cops and criminals here I
mean I understand the law and following
or whatever guideline but I mean
sometimes you got to make a decision you
know what I mean certain things you got
to live with other things that you live
with that you
like when you when you put your head on
a pillow at night you have to think
about
oh yeah yeah of course
um
I don't actually be honest with you I
don't I don't put my head on my pillow
and I rest easy every night because yeah
hell yeah I do because everything I've
ever done in my life I can justify ain't
nobody in this planet could tell me that
I didn't because I've I've never just
wronged somebody or wronged somebody
I've never tried to take advantage of
the week I don't do none of that [ __ ]
that's why I can't sleep at night with
my with my head held I and I sleep easy
I mean as long as I'm justified in it
I'm good I don't let nobody else dictate
my justification that's we're straight
on that
because it was the craziest
things you got into
uh prisoner oh man I've been all kinds
I've been in prison riots uh let's see
um I've been in five prison riots I
stabbed five people in prison or four
people in prison I didn't determine
issue almost nine years out of 14 I was
in I was in the shoes so I was very
confinement I mean I got out with 176
points um
almost didn't get out to be honest with
you you know I mean um I wouldn't even I
mean I was a knucklehead in prison
straight up right in the county jail so
I got there 18 years old [ __ ] bombing
all [ __ ] riding uh
Brian [ __ ] I mean Brian [ __ ] have you
mellowed with age
I don't know it's like again when I got
out here I started getting shootouts and
all kinds of [ __ ] I recently just got
into a shootout with these prices how
long you been out I've been out for uh
since 2015 so about seven years now
I think you'll be going back anytime I
don't want to yeah hell no I don't want
to God God permits I ain't going back
I'm a little bit smarter than that I'm
trying to figure it out I mean
how many kids you have I got two we got
two boys
are you in their lives huh are you in
their lives yeah we have them in their
lives yeah I'm their dad
um Sometimes women don't want you to be
in their lives though for some reason
that's what I'm saying uh yeah I'm
battling that right now but other than
that yeah hell yeah I'll be in their
lives I got my son back when I got out
of prison after doing 14 years I got my
son back from CPS
um that was one of my main goals you
know Mr Nicholas he's 21 now
uh I was in prison this whole pretty
much his whole life and when I got out
um I mean obviously I wasn't the best
candidate they failed to get him back
but I spent a lot of time in the shoe
doing a lot of smart stuff like studying
studying law studying uh just
understanding a lot of stuff and before
I went to prison I would say illiterate
I just have to write I just have to draw
pictures of like is it writing the word
I just brought the picture of whatever
it was you went but uh yeah I went to
prison I kind of educated myself I read
a lot of a lot of books and made my mind
expand with that time that I did and uh
I got out here and I was able to beat
CPS I pumped them you know me punked
them took back my property yeah my son
that was mine that's mine you mean I got
my son back I raised him from pretty
much 14 until he graduated high school
everything was good with that and I just
had to be I just had a baby my son
chasing I'm a big boy with this girl
right now and she just took off to the
other side of the country so she thinks
she's gonna beat me but she's gonna beat
me I'll be here in court and getting
back right you take after your dad you
think hell yeah I think that's my dad
I'm proud of it too
but yeah my dad was my hero I mean
he he me and him were having a little
issues when he died you know what I mean
and uh
I just wish that's one thing I ain't
gonna do is die guilty like him he felt
a lot of guilt that he couldn't he
couldn't shed you know I mean he
couldn't shed it for nothing about us
about his kids my little brother just
took 32 years in prison for murder this
was just like come on what six months
ago and uh my sisters they're off the
hook you mean I mean they settled down
but they all got their issues all of us
are on drugs or I've been on drugs in
the past I mean we're not we're not
where where we should be I mean so our
parents take to hit on that but my dad
he was in prison a lot of years and he
gets he just didn't know how to deal
with the guilt I mean mom made him feel
guilty and then what he sees in front of
him he just he don't know how to adapt
with it no matter how much I would tell
him man ain't nothing for you to feel
guilty about without my dad's without
the things my dad taught me I feel like
I would have been a victim in this world
you mean because it's not necessarily
just because you come over here you got
this good upbringing that you're gonna I
was in prison with people that were
straight college kids they were going
USC they made one mistake because the
prison the prison system is going to eat
you up there's so many laws and so many
[ __ ] even the good kids get eventually
put in there you mean they don't belong
in there well the difference between
them was I grew up in a way that my dad
was teaching me from a young age dude I
was running mugs with him uh how to how
to maneuver how to how to play the game
you know what I mean so at 18 years old
I was running yards and [ __ ] like I
shouldn't even had that experience I was
already knowing what you are what who
who's this you mean I was able to
maneuver and Shark Tank where I've seen
people my age get victimized immediately
I mean
and that's and that's just the real real
lovely so my dad died guilty feeling
guilty for something he shouldn't feel
guilty for because like I said
a man could have have a kid and he might
not be there his whole life but the
impact he leaves like like when people
when a man goes off to war right he has
a baby right
him being there and being that like
nowadays they make it seem like you got
to be like some old fem like feminist
[ __ ] makes men feel like they got to be
there and just toddling that's not what
our part is in life our part is to be in
the rock you mean the bass the strength
I mean and that's why a lot of this [ __ ]
that's happening in the world with with
all the breaking down the family
structure and all that actually that's
where it was coming from you mean it's
men ain't men no more I mean it's like
you gotta this world's tough dude if you
sit there and try to cuddle your kids
all you're doing is doing them
disservice you mean they're gonna
[ __ ] fail based off what your
parenting is but everybody out here gets
this political correct [ __ ] [ __ ]
to hear and they're telling people
[ __ ] oh yeah you know this is the
best Forum it's not the best for me I
mean best form is teaching lessons that
are hard and teach them that the world's
dangerous and you go out there and you
face it I mean you don't you don't lean
on other people people are supposed to
be able to lean on a man the man is not
always going to get some uh attaboy or
that that's not gonna get I mean you
don't get the reward that's the way it
is so what you mean you gotta live you
gotta get your rewards somewhere else
sometimes you mean and rewards are
setting an example so that you know your
kids are prepared for whatever that
whatever life throws at them you mean
I'd rather do that and in bed sometimes
like I said to The Establishment or
whoever the [ __ ] is making the [ __ ]
status quo that's a bad thing that's on
them dude I mean like I don't feel bad
about none of that [ __ ] and I might not
be the Polish [ __ ] thing they want in
front of him but I don't give a [ __ ]
straight up I don't give a [ __ ]
have drugs been a part of your life
are they still
um well yeah I mean sometimes
sometimes but I keep you within the
navigational beacons I mean try to I
mean I ain't all strung out like I'm not
scared rolling yeah you're functional
I'm functional right I mean you wouldn't
even be able to probably tell like you I
do drugs right I work out every day I
mean I keep on I keep on point but I do
know that it did the drugs are pretty
much a waste of time I do know that so
when I do do them I do them for whatever
purposes I know there's some core core
reason that I do them whatever but
I mean I quit him if I have to you and I
do I mean so I'm not I'm not slave to
that I never had to be like whatever bad
after school special where people are
sucking dick for [ __ ] dope and [ __ ]
like that ain't even gonna be me I mean
so but and I don't like the fact that
everybody that does drugs they usually
has some kind of [ __ ] crush or some
kind of [ __ ] uh justification for
what they do when they're [ __ ] being
courage I mean like come on dude thanks
I've been high as a [ __ ] kite
dude mushrooms acid PCP uh all of them
all of them at once and I've never had
an excuse like I get some [ __ ] foul
[ __ ] nah I'm just High I mean and I sure
as [ __ ] know I can't stand a person
that's what I'm dealing with right now
my baby's mom gets off gets off drugs
right she's been clean a year and all of
a sudden she's [ __ ] hot Holy Roller
on a [ __ ] on a steed walking around
acting like she's better than all this
you know I mean but it's like come on
man Facebook is [ __ ] facts and you're
like just cause you're on drugs if you
ain't dealing with what who you are as a
person might as well be back on drugs
most of the time to get out drugs in
their [ __ ] boring bunk and [ __ ]
talking dumb [ __ ] like we'll be on drugs
these are cool [ __ ]
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life oh
[ __ ] there's all kinds of lessons you
learn in life one that uh
nobody wants to see a man cry nobody
nobody in this world wants to see it
dude so don't don't even sit there and
try to cry because you're just wasting
your [ __ ] time that's number one
number two at the end of the day when
you find yourself at the loneliest part
of whatever whatever you're going
through it's gonna be you that picks
yourself up dude it's not gonna be some
[ __ ] psychotropic man it's not gonna
be some [ __ ] some [ __ ] whatever
you a higher power I believe in that
because I face that straight up I've
been shot when I got shot in the head
like that that right there proved it to
me that it was a higher power than
everything else in my life that's
happened is fate or some kind of higher
power for doing it I mean but I believe
that has direct connection to the to the
to the universe really I mean your
connection with the universe or whatever
internal thing you talk to inside your
head you manifest whatever you want I
mean so whatever you want to see happen
it all comes from in here you mean it's
whatever that is so
I mean that's my lessons I don't know
you believe in karma [ __ ] yeah I believe
in karma [ __ ] I used to think I was an
instrument of karma
and a lot of people who think I was an
instrument of karma that's what I say if
I'm at your door you did something wrong
all right how does camera play out in
your life okay well that's that's a good
thing right so you can't control what
the master say about you right ever no
matter what you do there's always gonna
be [ __ ] handful of people hate you
man a handful that pretend to like you
because you're around I'm sure the
comments on this video are going to be
oh yeah this guy's an [ __ ]
but uh especially with me especially my
hometown a little bit baby I'm the usual
suspect always so I ain't tripping but
you don't care I don't give a [ __ ]
dude what could I do to change it
anyways [ __ ] I like it you know and you
said I call the cops and get them give
me busted as fast but I mean they all
call cops they're all [ __ ] they're all
[ __ ] fake I mean if that's what they
are they'll get weeded out I mean I
don't want I don't want a bunch of
friends I wanna I want a handful of
friends that I can trust that's it the
rest of them I don't need none of them I
mean so 99 of them could follow the
Wayside for me but that could but that
also comes down to whoever your friends
are you gotta you gotta actually use
your [ __ ] mind and pick qualities in
people not just go like this dude
because I don't want to [ __ ] tell him
oh let's see remember you're my homeboy
I love you bro that's some [ __ ] do
you have good friends huh you have good
friends I'm [ __ ] best friends in my
life you mean and then I can count them
all on one hand
I mean straight up that's the way it
should be you don't need a lot you just
need a few yeah and the other things I'm
dealing with some [ __ ] like that like
right like you know if you have friends
from when you're a kid right
this is the theory I have and I'm pretty
sure it's based on some kind of fact out
there is you shouldn't be friends with
somebody that you grew up with as a kid
right unless that person is literally
doing a growing with you I mean so who
you've become 20 years down the road is
going to be none it shouldn't resemble
nothing of what was when you meant right
and both of you guys should be able to
see that and have went along the path
you know I mean like giving out trust
and giving out loyalty these qualities
that people just toss around actually
don't make no sense to me dude like
loyalty is a long extended contract dude
with somebody you know what I mean and
it can be changed in a second because a
lot of people a lot of people I made
friends with that dude for 20 years
right no you haven't that dude just wait
some people are just waiting to cast
your friendship in like I can take it
you mean like oh well here's a few
thousand dollars is that person really
bam cash you in yummy it's you you if
you're gonna really look at it like
loyalty is it's like smoking the [ __ ]
smoke through a keyhole you know what I
mean like doesn't exist unless somebody
else is adhering to the same quality or
say a hearing to the same value system
anyway that's what I think trust is the
same way if you don't trust can be
broken but trust to establish trust it's
got to be a long standing contract and
love is the same way too people think
that I love your dog I love you they
toss that [ __ ] word around me nobody
knows what the [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ]
meaning of it is you can have different
meanings of it but at the end of the day
love is something that is a two-way
street uh somebody has to prove to you
that they love you and you prove to them
that they love you and that's what keeps
it intact you know I mean the moment you
start seeing somebody and showing the
same thing to you that's a wrap yeah and
then there ain't no reason to sit there
and [ __ ] [ __ ] anymore I mean
you're blind to it because you want to
sit there and hold on to somebody oh
some more whatever they call it a
controlling [ __ ] uh whatever it is
cycle or whatever just that's it you
mean cut it off and you are who you hang
out with you are who an extended
decision you make the indecisions that
you have that's another thing you get
held back by these indecisions and then
cry about it you mean like you're
miserable to cut do something about it
dude I mean cut them off see what
happens might be surprised
I think [ __ ]
what are some of the roughest things
you've gotten into either prison or
outside okay well I'll see the okay I've
been to four four different level four
prisons I was in new Folsom 180 BR right
that was a shoe kick out yard I've been
to Old Corcoran 270 level three right
I've been a sentinela level uh level
level four 270 and 270 is the design of
the building right so that means he's
got three 90 degree angles right so it's
an exposed building a 180 it has three
sections and it's all broken down and as
far as security structure I mean so this
section is cut off to where walls are
between it and there's only 13 cells so
it eliminates the amount of people that
come out of the cells so that they can
thick and they can like contain the
violence right so on a level four yard
you're gonna have everything's contained
like so if a stabbing happens right it's
going to be contained to the one section
one tier you mean that's the way they do
it on level four and everything's locked
down on level four right now now what
makes this what makes it more deadly is
everybody goes to level four right
anybody that's been a prison contested
this right you go to prison and first of
all you got a bunch of you got this in
California mainly our politics school
like this you got active people right
and then you got non-active [ __ ]
people that are in jail right okay so
they're asking people are gang members
or whether they be white Mexican black
whatever right they hold a structure
they hold a uh they pretty much run
prison for inmates in there outside the
cops and their rules everything else is
ran by these structures I mean these uh
uh these active individuals right then
you had this person that came out and
they had to start figuring out what they
were gonna do with people that got
victimized off yards whether it be Tomos
or people that were invalidated in the
shoe right so if you're validating the
shoe you can't get out of you when back
now you can start letting everybody out
but they create they created the same
called the security housing unit that
was supposed to be a jail within the
jail so that they could quarantine these
people that they believe were running
the politics inside prison which they
were you mean yeah the Aaron Brotherhood
you had the Mexican Mafia you had no
extra Familia Texas Syndicate whatever
you never really see Texas indicator in
California they ain't running [ __ ] but
they are on they are a part of the
[ __ ] disruptive group they didn't
have skinheads right skinheads will
disrupt the group then yeah Nazi low
riders right so what they did was once
he created these shoes with inside of
the shoe the the administration had to
hold on to those like they were job they
were job opportunities for everybody
because the shoe has to run 24 hours has
to have a certain amount of staff has to
have all that [ __ ] and it's all the way
to the Bare Bones like when you're in
the shoe I'll say this they actually out
right there that [ __ ] will make you
crazy for one it is going to be crazy
over time it's gonna be straight up
[ __ ] shoe syndrome uh people in there
just isolation just breaks down human
conditions right so that's where I was
at most of the time
but uh when I when you get on a level
four politics will start that's where
everything's at so you know you guys
usually go to prison and they get all
these tattoos and [ __ ] but they're on
level one yards right level one yard
ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] nobody nobody's doing
time up there but they'll get out here
I'm [ __ ] active bro I'm running [ __ ]
but they're doing nothing they're out
there quilts with their [ __ ] shower
shoes on the yard and [ __ ] man but uh
then before straight politics though now
it's not it's kind of [ __ ] way out
politics because you got a person that's
got two years to go home right but he's
gonna have to run a level four programs
which is all lifers all people that are
that they're gonna kill you they're not
[ __ ] around with you they're gonna
kill you so if you have two years and
you have to follow the same manuscript
they're following you're I mean you'd be
lucky yeah that's what happened with me
I went in with four years four years
eight months for carjacking when I was
18 years old as soon as I got to love
soon I got the yard boom blasted [ __ ]
chomo uh in reception as a matter of
fact got the first home I ever got right
there breaker broke his head open
[ __ ] got my first shoe 15 month shoe
I didn't go out to court for that one I
mean because I was there anything I was
under the impression that uh because I
was a kid I was always hanging out with
older homeboys out here being I was in
the mix like at 15 I was out of running
around with older homeboys and [ __ ] from
prison so I believe a lot of these fools
in their in their prison lore and he
definitely got gratified to me to where
I was like I was ready to go man I felt
like I had to go to prison my dad's one
thing I will say I felt like I had to go
to prison I had to go to prison but
you're a kid hell yeah I did hell yeah I
would have I would have had it any other
way even though I had a lot of people
are going like scroll down [ __ ]
I didn't give a [ __ ] I was going out
that was a bang I mean what is that the
testosterone that was just no it's just
just the image I mean just like you said
you grow up my dad was an outlaw dude I
mean he drove a Cadillac with bull horns
on it and cowboy hat he had a [ __ ]
trans code talked to the country accent
he was wild you mean cook mads [ __ ]
wrote Harley Davidsons [ __ ] at two
two forty fives and [ __ ] gun holsters
I understand I idolized that dude that
was a role model that was my role model
but there was a lot back in that day
like back in the 90s and 80s you're
talking about some serious some serious
people back then you mean so that that
whole atmosphere definitely bred into me
that I needed to walk that path I mean
now I feel obviously that was not the
wrong right path you mean or maybe I
could have done maybe I could have been
that without having to go down there on
path but I don't think that even comes
they can't do that I mean you got to be
if you're gonna be that way you're gonna
have to accept all the [ __ ] all the
consequences of it but yeah so my dad
sent me on that path and I will say he
did that and I walked that path pretty
good too I mean I was never I was never
a victim I'll tell you that much I was
on the level four yard 11 12 years you
know I never got sad victimized I mean I
got seven riots but I never got
victimized I'll tell you that much I was
a political [ __ ] Guru I was a buffalo
you know I mean like I didn't give a
[ __ ] if I had it if I had two days to go
home I'll stab you just same same as I
stab you if I had 20 years with me
that's what but that's that's it that's
for real because the moment you show any
weakness in there you might as well just
be like blood in the water it starts to
come for you so
um I remember let's see I'm gonna hear
about a prison Ryan I'll tell you about
some prison life I'll tell you about
something that only people have been in
prison will raise you right so I'm in
Santa Nella
level four I've ever been on in my life
was that [ __ ] was straight up 125
degrees
no I thought it was it was like being in
Mexico straight up I mean because every
cop there is Mexican you know he's right
there on the Imperial Valley so it's
right there on by the Mexican border
near me in the middle of nowhere by the
Salton Sea uh every cop there I mean
even the [ __ ] [ __ ] on the intercoms
in Spanish you know noodles
and the Mexicans are outnumber everybody
like there's literally times at five out
of five billion you'd have two white
cells that's four white boys in a whole
building the rest of them all Mexican or
black majority of Mexicans right and
they're they're loked up right so you go
to the yard at 125 degree weather I'm
talking it's cooking [ __ ] out there you
got the lizards running around with
[ __ ] sticks and she like usually hang
on so they don't burn up and [ __ ] and uh
I got the keys to the yard right so we
got to deal with all that [ __ ] so the
Mexicans are non-stop politicians all
about dope and [ __ ] stabbing somebody
and I've been on level fours where I've
heard the mentality straight up we
haven't stab somebody in a week talking
Charlotte's gonna get flagged like
they're looking for people to just to
victimize because to them the more
violence that happens on this yard that
establishes some kind of uh uh nobility
in this yard it's like what the [ __ ] got
a sick ass mindset is that right but I
used to I used to trip because and this
person is like you have it be that hot
there's just like it's like a cooker
yummy it's like a [ __ ] brain cooker
everything's [ __ ] hot everybody's
pissed off chance and then you got these
in the background you always have it
non-stop it's like a was that a Chinese
torture where they used to talk about
when you just dripped it's like that but
it's a psychological warfare because
you've got these cops that are in the
just just enough in the distance where
they're shooting at [ __ ] silhouette
[ __ ] targets and [ __ ] amazing
[ __ ] mean 14 and it's happening the
whole time it's just like even when I
parole I was like I can still hear it
may not be like we're walking to Chow
and then uh stabbing what happened right
we'd all have to get down I'm talking
people getting butchered dude two dudes
on one dude [ __ ] butchering them and
then the cops get over there throw maze
bombs whatever they patch them up they
don't even clean up the blood stains on
the yard I mean literally you can walk
around and you do you walk around the
yard you see oh there's that stand
there's that bunch of rubber gloves and
[ __ ] blood stains only cleans it up and
you're in this
what the [ __ ] some psycho ass [ __ ] and
wonder why we why we do what we do I
mean you get institutionalized uh what
is what is institutionalized if it's
just like means I want to go back to
prison that sure [ __ ] me I mean I
don't want to go back but uh
I don't know I guess institutionalizes
being able to adapt to that I don't know
get used to it yeah but I mean so then
it's too less institutionalized with
anything that really I don't know what I
don't know what defines the
institutionalism I guess they would say
I was I mean I've been going to jail my
whole life is that does that mean
standards I don't know I just [ __ ] don't
want to go back to jail at all at no
cost I'd rather have them just smoke me
in the streets and go back to that
[ __ ] place I don't think I could have
day if I had to do the time that I did
now right this second after I'm getting
out here it's like that uh what was that
uh philosopher I think Aristotle or
something he wrote that that story about
the man on the rock you ever heard about
that story where he talks about the
man's all the Rockies whole life for
like 30 years of his life right and all
he can do is watch the world behind him
through Shadows on the cave right so
he's on this rock and the whole time he
wants to [ __ ] off his Rock he's like
looking at the shadows and that's what
his world's been he says he's watching
this [ __ ] world from from the shadows
of it right so they finally take him off
the rock it comes off the Rock and you
turn around you see what he's been
watching this whole time right within
[ __ ] matter of minutes he's like
[ __ ] overwhelmed by it he's like what
the [ __ ] this is whoa it's outside of my
comfort zone so we want to go back on
the Rock right so they go all right I'll
put you back on the Rock put him back on
the rocky that's it once your eyes are
open you're stuck you mean this
[ __ ] can't come off the rock
he's sucking it in like some [ __ ]
liberateth or whatever they call it like
I mean in between Purgatory type [ __ ]
you know I mean so I don't know if
that's the case I do feel like that
though because I don't want to go back
to prison for [ __ ] and I don't I I mean
sometimes out here though I remember
when I was going to get parole out here
I was telling myself like
the worst day out here can't be it's got
the worst day out here out here it's got
to be better than any day in there you
know I mean but sometimes you find
yourself depressed out here and prison
comes in a lot of different forms too it
doesn't necessarily mean it's being
incarcerated in a prison system it could
be a prison in mind prison in a [ __ ]
situation I mean that's why you have
people killing themselves out here at
all time you mean so I don't know I feel
like I guess I'd probably fall in
institutionalism I my brother I mean he
just took 32 years a deal 32 years for a
murder I mean shot somebody killed them
and right before that when I gotta shoot
out with these with these prices and
[ __ ] they came to my house trying to
shoot me the AR-15 I had my I have my
baby's mom with me my two dogs and uh it
was over a dispute over money 10 grand
you mean and these fools came up thought
they were gonna bully me the day before
because I introduced him to this dude
and uh they thought they were gonna
bully me they came back and told me
because all I did was introduce them to
somebody you know what I mean so then he
full decided that they're supposed to be
moochicon cartel or some [ __ ] I was
doing some weed business because they do
a lot of weed business repairs and uh I
introduced him to a Mexican dude and
been typical fashion these boys try to
they were gonna burn me anyways I didn't
speak Spanish anyway so as soon as I
interviewed some Mexican music Spanish I
already knew what time it was but this
dude was my homeboy I thought he burned
them right so these ones come to me
you're gonna have to [ __ ] kill this
dude or [ __ ] kill you man it's a
[ __ ] America dog like you ain't gonna
push up on me I ain't no [ __ ] punk I
mean when they were like oh we'll be
back so I went and got a gun [ __ ] put
in my trailer I'm an ex-felon so I
already knew what time it was you mean I
didn't want to have to shoot out with
these fools I just figured pretend to
have Farmers you mean maybe they weren't
what they say they were but they came
back the next morning and uh me and my
baby's mom were and they said this RV on
the property and [ __ ] and so they rolled
up and uh I'm sleeping I'm in my sweats
and [ __ ] I got my [ __ ] nine
millimeter right there
my two dogs right there and I hear a
[ __ ] and my chick wakes him she's
like hey
what the [ __ ] I look at the window I'm
like I ain't the cops it's too Mexican
right well one of them standing there
with a 45
talking [ __ ] in Spanish what the [ __ ]
and the other dude behind him looks like
a little little youngster like a little
parrot mustache she said I know the
AR-15 shaking like Leaf right all right
cool I've been in I've been in some
gunfights so I mean I wasn't that uh
ill-prepared I've seen the situation was
I seen the fear level so I was like all
right at least that's good right there I
don't know why they didn't start dumping
on the trailer from the beginning I mean
if you're gonna come kill a [ __ ]
and they came to kill me because they
came out later on when all that [ __ ]
ended up happening they came there to
kill me but they didn't they didn't just
handled it mishandled it I guess but I
opened the door thing okay well here it
goes you may have told her get on the
bed open the door while having a pit
bull and a little uh like a American
Dingo dog in Me Love My Dog stomper
anyways I opened the door and that
fool's standing there talking [ __ ]
pointing this gun at me right hey look
[ __ ] what's up I show them I got
a gun figure you mean what are we gonna
do here my dog runs out there
immediately and starts [ __ ] attacking
oh tearing them up right so the kid the
youngster gets panicked and jumps in the
car and [ __ ] starts backing out Bob
right
so I tell that dude I already knew it
was gonna happen because this dude's
looking at me and my dog's [ __ ] him
up you know I mean I'm like man you
shoot my dog home boy I'm gonna have to
blast you and I'm thinking the whole
time I'm going I'm going back to prison
I'm going back to prison I'm going back
no matter what he's a California
self-defense um I never heard nobody get
that [ __ ] I mean I'm an ex felon so I'm
like I'm committed once he does that I
gotta do what I gotta do so he ended up
shooting my dog in the head my dog takes
off you mean and uh once you shot the
dog there's a my old age car was right
between them and I gave Park their SUV
like right here so they're in between
the cars and I was in the RV so when he
shot my dog I said all right
[ __ ] came out popped two shots
at him I jumped behind the car he he
went over here like at least over and
started dumping right he dumped the
whole clip I'm sitting there like this
watching the boys go
I got you [ __ ] you mean well my
old lady could run out right because she
heard a dog right she's five months
pregnant with my son at the time so she
came around stop it [ __ ] runs off I'm
like [ __ ] well he takes off running
right after he emptied his clip that kid
was taken off of that without him you
mean trying to leave so I'm like all
right I'm on the run you mean so I
counted my bullets I fired off to you I
got 11 11 total and nine millimeter so
boom boom I shot off too I'm standing
behind the car I see him go around and
tell him the Spanish the rifle the rifle
was the rifle through the thing now he's
at the [ __ ] truck into Shield right
and she starts lighting me up boom boom
boom boom AR-15 so I'm behind the car
he's hitting the car boom boom I call
under the [ __ ] RVs right
my chicks made it to the porch by the
time my dog's on the front porch getting
attacked by my mom's boyfriend's dogs
that are up there my mom's boyfriend was
in there or some [ __ ] he didn't know
what's going on so he's like what the
[ __ ] all he had is all he had in the
house is a like a BB gun right well
those automatic bb guns so he doesn't
know what's really going on so he can
run out of that he needs some old man
and [ __ ] but he came out he came out to
handle the [ __ ] anyway so uh these
people start backing out right and
they're still lighting me up so I come
outside our other side of the trailer
and I'm like well I don't know what
they're gonna do they're still unloading
on me but they're trying to leave right
so I'm like [ __ ] man if I if I kill him
and they're leaving it is that still
sell stuff for the fancy I mean but
they're still unloading on me right so
I waited a lot longer than the
detectives later on they're like why'd
you wait so long like you should have
just [ __ ] ended them dude like you
you and Amanda you guys life was in
danger from the moment they rolled up on
the property she just ended them but me
being [ __ ] me I'm like [ __ ] I want to
make sure I don't go backwards for the
rest of my life because it's over they
wouldn't got me anyways I was gonna kill
myself before that but anyways he was
going to the game right and so I come
out in the open now right and it's just
dump it on me bam bam bam I can see dirt
coming up Paul comes out he's like
somebody with a BB gun right I'm like
what the [ __ ] you do you know this was
behind the truck now right the truck
stop bam you got loads of he pops out a
clip pops another one in I'm like damn
this motherfucker's serious about
killing me right oh by the cactus and he
starts lighting me up like a Philly
bullets just going right by me
and my chick's still up on the front
porch [ __ ] with the dogs and so I
just [ __ ] took aim on this
[ __ ] and just unloaded bro and
he has 30 yards out too you know he came
out like this Pokemon
check him on the side of the head boom
drop it
so when I dropped him I'm like all right
cool I mean I only had two more bullets
left in the gun and the driver stopped
at the gate jumped out I thought he was
gonna grab the gun so I just shot the
last two at him I didn't get him but he
got to do his body [ __ ] threw in the
truck and then ran to the gate he took
off right Paul's all chasing [ __ ]
bear
[ __ ] uh when he comes back I'm
tripping because I'm like I look over
and next door to us we live in like a
rat style houses where we're living at
so the lady the night before she does
horse training for the sheriff's
department so she was already on point
she had already called the cops the
night before saying this [ __ ] white
SUV was driving up and down so she must
have been on point she was a year The
Gunshot she came out with her little
[ __ ] tablet and was like caught a
hotel into the shooting I mean like I'm
like what the [ __ ] so like it's all bad
I tell Paul here to take his gun right I
gotta go you know I run up in the
portion and when I get in there my dog's
[ __ ] squirting blood like like a
[ __ ] like a faucet out of his
forehead
and he lives by the way my dog lived he
get old cream or nothing right same
thing as me I mean toughest [ __ ]
so anyways by the time I thought he was
dying so I grabbed my dog and my old age
oh yeah it's your [ __ ] [ __ ] I
saw your [ __ ] father you know what
the [ __ ] worst time to start bitching in
a [ __ ] initiating me but I got
the dog in my [ __ ] jump in the car
bam we start taking off watch apolly get
rid of that gun whatever the [ __ ] we
make it to the veterinarian place the
first one he told us [ __ ] out mind you
I'm in sweatpants no [ __ ] uh
shirt on nothing covered in blood I got
the dog got the [ __ ] [ __ ] running
her mouth like you mean I pull up on
they're like you're not get out of here
right so we go to the next one and I'm
already know the cops are gonna come
there ain't no [ __ ] way I'm
already in trouble I know that for a
fact so when we get up there they act
like they were gonna help us they went
in there with the dog came back out said
we had 2 300 bucks I'm like [ __ ] no I
got no 2200 bullets just help the dog
you know what I mean they just jumped
right there and that was all bad I
didn't punching the glass out of the
[ __ ] basement airing place you know I
mean well I get on my phone and I manage
still talking [ __ ] so I get on my phone
I'm like call everybody I call him call
him Bobby I was calling everybody in my
circle like I need [ __ ] help dude
come get me I mean so my buddy Luke and
my one of my best friends Luke and his
old lady come come show them these were
the characters like a [ __ ] right
they don't ask me nothing don't ask me
what I'm in trouble with they don't give
a [ __ ] they're coming to get me right so
I'm standing there I get a message on my
phone I don't even know what the numbers
from it's like yo like yo who the [ __ ]
is this I mean oh this officer thornock
with the Bears PD [ __ ] where you at
Baker I'm like why am I in trouble man
you like uh no you're not in trouble man
where you at that's odd I don't normally
get caught you know calls from Cops
Diego so I tried calling him he goes oh
my antenna ain't working well later a
newspaper since they were trying to use
some aerial [ __ ] ping in my phone
[ __ ] I mean with the helicopter so I
told them Temecula yeah man I'm in
Marietta anyway so he's like that's
where that ends but well it very opinion
anyway so they had all this whole time
I'm standing there they didn't know how
to approach me but they were having cop
cars come in boom boom boom like real
cop cars you couldn't even tell whether
they were cop cars they were like
[ __ ] soccer mom bands and [ __ ] so
they had about 10 of them 15 of them
were surrounding me my homeboy pulls up
with his old lady Brittany comes right
out what's up let's go she doesn't even
ask it I'm covering the blood she didn't
even look at it she's like let's go
[ __ ] jump in the car and [ __ ]
so man I'm gone I mean figure it out so
me and her and and her and Luke they're
they're [ __ ] characters like you've got
them on this [ __ ] you'd be laughing like
a [ __ ] but uh these fools are
like oblivious you know I mean I'm
sitting in the back I'm going but I'm
talking I'm texting Bobby I'm like I'm
going back prison and uh Luke and they
were fighting over some [ __ ] like I
want to go to Starbucks
it was uh when I pulled in your uh
unmarked cop car came and be honest
where's it at it was just like right
there one unmarked cop car right like
what's he doing he goes oh he ain't
tripping on us and we started pulling
out there's like all them other cop cars
I told you they were undercover
Community tail they're all pulling out
behind us right so he's like ah that
comes way behind he's like can't carved
behind us and [ __ ] I go nah he's coming
for us but he's like no he's not he
ain't tripping our asses he's gonna trip
on a cracked window i'm like [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] so we come out into the [ __ ]
main strip right and uh all these cars
are following us right I said hey Luke
what's up with that unmarked cop car
back there he's like he goes I think
there's something up like why he goes uh
well there's about seven black and white
back there now I'm like oh is that right
he goes yeah because they're coming up
with their lights blaring right as soon
as they get to the unmarked cop car they
go they shut their lights off it's our
phone right I go here turn in this park
right here as soon as we turn to the
park it was like [ __ ] movie dude like
[ __ ] [ __ ] 40 cops you [ __ ]
helicopters they got inside the car at
gunpoint and [ __ ] and I was like they
got Luke out they got Brittany out [ __ ]
and [ __ ] got me out well when you got me
out dude I ain't gonna lie I was pretty
much look at the situation I was like
that's probably why is that just maybe
do death by cop or something I mean but
uh I'm glad I didn't do it because I was
really close and just act like I had a
gun I mean that's the idiot right there
it'd be better that way cause I wasn't
trying to go back to prison for the rest
of my life and [ __ ] but it ended up
working out because we went down police
station they questioned me it turns out
that the prices they got killed he was
still unconscious kinda so he took him
down to the hospital and [ __ ] uh the
dude that took him as soon as the cops
rolled up on him and he told the cops to
arrest him you know I mean like they
arrest me yeah he's worried about
whatever's gonna happen to him because
he didn't finish his job you know so
they went out and opened his car found a
thousand rounds shotgun another machine
gun [ __ ] all this crazy [ __ ] and uh
he pretty much told him the story like
yeah we were there to kill him and
confirmed all that [ __ ] right so I'm
sitting there and they're like they
found in my in my RV they found two
extended clips for a Glock a Glock
millimeter a Glock uh 17 two extended
clips they found a [ __ ] DEA badge a
[ __ ] bulletproof vest they found uh
the gun with the bullets I mean so but
these detectives when they come in like
I've been through I've been going of
course since I was 11. so I know what
time it is you know I mean so I'm not
gonna sit here and tell them nothing I'm
not gonna fall for another that [ __ ]
giving up my [ __ ] you mean so I don't
want to lower it immediately but these
cops would be so cool right there's like
we already know man we already know the
whole story right they're more enamored
which I don't know if that was fake or
what but they were more enamored like
man dude you [ __ ] you killed this
[ __ ] you were getting blasted at
you I mean like and then they said no
matter what happens you even know your
family they're like the fact you didn't
have that gun if you wouldn't have that
gun you wouldn't matter baby all that
[ __ ] would have been dead I mean so you
could look at however you want to do if
they pick up a case on it that's once
you go into court on you mean if you
didn't have that gun you didn't make
that decision to have that gun you would
have been dead you know and then they
told me to get out of Paris after that
but they ended up cutting me loose at
night and they follow they fell in The
Possession firearm but they gave me a
justifiable homicide on the on the
homicide you mean they entertaining that
dude to jail but he bailed out you know
he's on the run and that was you know
that was it did you do it anytime no not
yet but see a week later I got busted
with the nut with a cool 45 right but
they told me to get out of Paris but I
ain't got no [ __ ] money to
leave Paris so I just rolling around my
Harley doing my thing yeah this just
happened recently it's just having a
reason I'm fighting the case right now
as a matter of fact I go to court I go
to court on in on Jan January [ __ ] but
uh that was a funny story too I was a
mushrooms I got busted with the [ __ ]
gun you mean but I mean even they cop
didn't want to bust me either because
he's like dude he's a periscope so he
heard about the shootout too he's like
man [ __ ] dude I feel bad and it the
Paris was the worst thing that ever
happened to me though that's a bad area
I'll tell you that one I know I got shot
right there I got [ __ ] that [ __ ]
happened so
desert is rough yeah Paris is no joke
dude that's like especially me value
that's a wild wild west like Little
Mexico Little Tijuana [ __ ] you know I
mean they don't [ __ ] around right there
they'll chop you up you know all right
Billy well thanks for all right bro sure
that's right that's great let's go along
good luck